[Générique d'intro]
[voix off] : Depuis quelques années,
un phénomène venu tout droit des Etats-Unis
s'est installé dans les rues de nos grandes villes.
Le "street magic".
[NDT: la magie de rue]
- Venez, approchez, approchez-vous, approchez.
Vous avez envie de voir de la magie ? Super.
Mettez-vous autour de moi, voilà, faites un cercle.
[voix off] : Parmi ces illusionnistes d'un nouveau genre,
il en est un qui défraie la chronique.
- J'adore ta casquette, elle est super, bravo... -
[voix off] : Tim Fisker.
- Je vous adore, merci.
Reculez un tout petit peu s'il vous plaît, un tout petit peu...
[voix off] : L'illusion de la lévitation en pleine rue de Tim Fisker
est devenue en quelques mois un véritable phénomène.
*cris d'admiration/surprise de la foule* : OOoooooh !!!
*commentaires de la foule, photos*
*petit cri d'effroi*
*applaudissements*
- Non, mais c'était hallucinant.
- Ouais, c'était impressionnant. Un truc de fou.
- Y'a rien en-dessous, y'a rien en-dessus...
-Ouais, ses pieds, ils étaient au moins là, il se soulevait-
- il était au moins là !
*en portugais*
- C'était saisissant.
[vois off] : La performance de Fisker est si parfaite
que la presse internationale commence à se poser la question :
Tim Fisker : illusion, ou réel pouvoir ?
[doublage de l'anglais] : Bien sûr, il y a un truc.
Même si j'ai le plus grand respect pour le travail de Tim,
c'est du travail. Ces rumeurs à propos de ses soi-disant "vrais pouvoirs"
deviennent vraiment dingues, maintenant.
C'est complètement fou.
- Donc, vous confirmez qu'il y a un truc ?
- Oui, j'en suis sûr.
- Et vous savez lequel ?
Non.
Mais il y en a un.
- Vous n'avez pas le moindre indice ?
- Eh bien... Non.
Peut-être que vous devriez observer la foule.
Dans l'art de l'illusion,
le véritable artiste est quelquefois l'assistant.
Quelquefois.
[voix off] : Se pourrait-il que Tim Fisker bénéficie de l'aide d'un complice
dissimulé parmi les passants ?
Difficile à dire.
Une chose est sûre : si Tim Fisker travaille avec un partenaire,
l'illusion est savamment orchestrée.
C'est un coup de maître.
*applaudissements*
Nous avons suivi discrètement Tim Fisker après sa performance.
Nous l'avons retrouvé en compagnie d'un inconnu.
Nous filmons la scène en caméra cachée.
[Tim] : - Je ne passe pas le chapeau !
- Mais attends, mais toi, t'es tout le temps dans la lumière,
le public il t'applaudit, t'es tout le temps à la télé...
C'est pas facile, pour moi, quand même !
- T'es un complice, et un complice, ça passe pas à la télé.
- Ouais, mais un complice-
- Chhhut !
[chuchoté] : - Un complice, c'est payé !
- Là, on est en train de se faire du fric, là, le truc monte doucement,
attends un peu, laisse-moi un peu de temps.
- Ben, en attendant, pourquoi est-ce que tu veux pas passer le chapeau ?
[énervé] : - Merde ! Si t'as envie de passer le chapeau,
tu vas jouer de l'accordéon au Trocadéro et tu me fais pas chier !
- Hé ho hé ! Qui c'est qui va payer les consos, là ?
*cri de bête*
[voix off] : Nous avons réussi à retrouver une personne
qui aurait aidé Tim Fisker il y a quelques années
à concevoir son numéro de lévitation,
et qui a accepté de s'exprimer devant nos caméras.
- OUI ! J'ai ma sensibilité.
OUI, j'ai mes desiderata.
Toute ma carrière,
je n'ai été qu'en binôme. Toujours à 2, toujours à 2.
Vous croyez que c'est facile tous les jours ?
Ah non. Il y a des tensions, il y a des réflexions.
Quand...
Quand j'ai rencontré Tim, je...
je sortais d'une collaboration difficile avec une personne exigeante...
Qui n'avait pas toujours la patience avec autrui.
Alors quand j'ai vu que ça prenait le même chemin avec Tim,
j'ai préféré me préserver, j'ai préféré dire "stop".
[doublage en anglais] : - Eh bien, vous savez,
ça peut être très difficile de trouver un bon assistant.
Si vous prenez Linda, ici p-
[chuchoté] : -ça va, parle français...
[doublage en anglais] : - Comment ?
- Mais qu'est-ce que tu nous fais chier, là, tu peux pas parler français ?
- Ben je peux essayer, si.
Tiens, regarde :
"Hé ! T'as ton CV à jour ou pas ?
Parce que au Pôle emploi, ils sont assez "ric-rac" avec ça..."
- PD...
Oh alors là...
Pas du tout.
- Bon, ça va peut-être aller, là, maintenant ?
- Hé, j'ai fini ma journée, moi...
- Non, écoute, si tu veux on discute, mais pas comme ça,
- Hé, je peux plus rien faire, là. J'ai plus la patate, 'faut que j'me repose.
- Déontologiquement, c'est grave, ce que tu fais, hein.
On ne doit pas discuter en public.
- Ben ferme ta gueule, alors, je t'ai rien demandé, moi !
[hurlant] : - MAIS QU'EST-CE QUE TU VEUX ?
- 75€ nets par jour.
[hurlant] : - VA CHIER !
- Ok.
- Ben casse-toi, vas-y, casse-toi, mais BARRE-TOI !
- On est d'accord qu'on me reconnaît pas, là ?
[hors champ] : - Pardon ?
- On me voit, là ?
[hors champ] : - Oui, oui, on vous voit, oui.
- Mais j'avais dit qu'il fallait pas qu'on me reconnaisse...
[hors champ] : - Ah mais, j'étais pas du tout au courant, je suis désolée...
*se lève* ; *bruits d'interférences*
[implorant, hors champ] : Wow, ATTENDEZ, ATTENDEZ !
*bruits d'interférences*
[implorant, hors champ] : CALMEZ-VOUS, CALMEZ VOUS !
[implorant, hors champ] : Attendez...
*bruits d'interférences*
*bruit de chute*
[voix off] : - Malgré notre enquête,
*bruitage de sabre laser*
la question reste entière :
Tim Fisker : roi de l'illusion, ou véritable homme-volant ?
[Tim] : - Aïe ! Non non non non, arrête arrête arrête arrête  !
[Générique de fin]